[Music]
few dc comics fans could have predicted
a few years ago that warner brothers
would release a new batman movie in 2022
that is not only set outside of the dc
extended universe but also stars someone
other than ben affleck as a caped
crusader
however that's exactly what has happened
now after entrusting war for the planet
of the apes director matt reeves with
its most coveted superhero property wb
has finally unveiled the robert
pattinson led the batman for everyone to
see
taking inspiration from multiple
different comic book and cinematic
sources the batman isn't like a lot of
the other comic book movies that have
come before it where the film adopts the
same kind of grounded gritty ascetic
that dominated christopher nolan's dark
knight trilogy the batman goes even
further with that style
the movie also leans harder into the
detective side of its titular character
delivering a movie that is not only a
superhero flick but also a thrilling and
genuinely intriguing crime mystery
thanks to the presence of its primary
villain edward nashton aka the riddler
the batman also gets incredibly dark at
certain points as a matter of fact it
may very well be the darkest live-action
batman movie that comic book fans have
ever seen
about fans beware spoilers ahead
from its opening scene the batman sets
ball danis riddler up to be the scariest
live-action villain in batman movie
history
opening with one long voyeuristic shot
from the characters pov the film's first
sequence sees riddler break into the
home of gotham city's mayor on halloween
night and brutally kill the man while
his family members are out
trick-or-treating the sequence is
unexpectedly dark and creepy but it's
only the first of the film's many
impactful and unsettling rhythmless
scenes
indeed over the course of its nearly
three-hour run time the batman follows
the riddler as he goes on a bloody and
gruesome crusade killing many of gotham
city's most powerful and corrupt law
enforcement officials
with each of his kills the riddler
reveals a little bit more about himself
and the relationship that he thinks he
has with pattinson's batman
however his main mission in the batman
is to expose the corruption that has run
rampant throughout gotham for decades by
killing the people who allowed the
city's citizens to be taken advantage of
lied to and kept in the dark
as a result the character who was
partially inspired by terrifying
real-life figures like the zodiac killer
sets out to send a different message
with each of the crime scenes he leaves
behind
with that in mind it's worth asking
which character in the batman experience
is the most gruesome death
due to the nature of his mission in the
batman the riddler leaves a surprisingly
high number of victims in his wake
indeed the villain performed several
heinous acts throughout the movie
including strapping a bomb to the neck
of gil coulson gotham city's corrupt
district attorney at one point in its
second act that said the most gruesome
death in the batman is actually the one
that fans see the least of in the film
itself and that's the murder of corrupt
police commissioner pete savage
introduced near the tail end of the
film's first crime scene sequence savage
is initially set up to be a major thorn
in the sides of both james gordon and
batman
however savage's presence and the batman
comes to a quick and unexpected end
early on in the film when he is revealed
to be the second of the riddler's
victims
unlike most of the deaths in the batman
savage's demise isn't shown on screen
when it happens
instead the character's death is
revealed in a news report which briefly
shows a video that the riddler recorded
during savage's last moments in it the
audience briefly sees savage sitting
with a complex trap strapped across his
chest and face
later in the film it is revealed that
the riddler injected savage with rat
poison and then placed the rats in the
trap on his body which eventually chewed
and buried into his face and neck the
complex depraved and drawn out nature of
savage's death is what makes it truly
horrifying to think about and that's
also why the batman ultimately shows
very little of it and only briefly
alludes to the state of savage's body
after he is discovered by his police
colleagues
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite dc movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]